welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar the current state
of the art tissue expression analysis
platform for detection and
quantification of target and biomarker
mRNAs splice variants and mutations in
preclinical and clinical tissues it is
presented by Christopher bunker PhD vice
president of business development at
Advanced Cell Diagnostics my name is
Judy O'Rourke and I will be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by Advanced Cell Diagnostics a
brand of biotech knee for more
information about our sponsor visit a CD
bio comm before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
and type your questions into the
drop-down box our speaker will respond
to your questions via email following
the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the ask a question box
to let us know that you're experiencing
a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits now
without further ado please join me in
welcoming dr. bunker I will now turn the
presentation over to him thank you Judy
and thank you all of you who joined for
this this webinar I'm happy to have a
chance to describe to you our RNA scope
technology and developed and
commercialized by Advanced Cell
Diagnostics and a random of a bio
technique so it is the current state of
the art for in situ hybridization based
expression analysis in fixed issues and
the areas that I'll speak about as
illustrations that are in the areas of
oncology biomarker development and
applications in the areas of cell and
gene therapy up
in relation to biodistribution analysis
again in the context of intact fixed
tissues so in the in eight years since
our any scope technology was first
commercialized it's seen a tremendous
rate of adoption in that time we've gone
from our first publication in 2012 for
2011 and now we are over 1,800 almost
1,900 publications with increasing
publications at a rate of almost 2 per
day
we have over 18,000 RNA scope in situ
hybridization probes in use we make
probes to virtually any sequence from
any species they all work under
identical conditions and it's proven to
be an extremely valuable way in a
tremendous versity diversity of research
areas for doing tissue based gene
expression analysis the the method is
organically died based the main features
of the assay are that it can be
performed on routine FFPE tissues so
unlike historical conventional methods
for doing integer Berta's ation which
are only really suitable for use on
frozen tissues this method was developed
with the primary purpose of enabling RNA
into translation on archival human
biopsies with the eventual intention of
developing diagnostics the the readout
is actually detection of individual
single molecules of RNA which can be
quantified on a per cell basis and
because it is oolagah nucleotide based
it is very reliable and extremely
specific and predictably specific based
on all of you nucleotide melting
temperatures so to give you just oh this
isn't basically workflow of the assay
again starting with routine FFP tissues
archival tissues 5-10 years old have
been used routinely with the method as
well as freshly collected clinical
biopsies and animal tissues from any
number of species all of the assays rely
on paired alga nucleotides for signal
amplification so shown here in the
second frame is an example of a pair of
Allah goes where the three prime ends
hybridize sequence specifically to the
target RNA and the five prime ends are
shown in a pairwise manner of
functioning to hybridize to the rest of
an amplification module which is shown
in the middle panel this allows for the
localization of thousands of copies of
label whether they're its HRP or
alkaline phosphatase or fluorophores all
localized to a single transcript which
results in enough signal to to detect
individual molecules on a personal basis
in tissue these assays run they do we do
have manual assays which are used
extensively in academic research our our
automated assays run on both antenna
discovery ultra and like a bond rx
instrumentation and those assays are
again fully automated from start to
finish a deep memorization to do
chromatin detection or Florist detection
so fully automated assay on any platform
that I'm going to now we'll create a few
of those examples but first a few more
details about the probes again they're
all gonna vary tides no special
requirements for preparation of samples
routine FFP tissues are what these are
intended to work on as shown here the
the region that a pair of ala goes
hybridizes to is about 50 nucleotides
each I'll go hybridize and about 25
nucleotides the top again functioning in
a pair will hybridize stabili to a
preamplifier which can then hybridize to
additional all goes for amplification a
typical probe actually consists of a
large pool of these all egos all tested
in silico such that we can be sure
before the probe is even made that each
one of the alga nucleotides is entirely
sequence specific for the intended
target the fact that it's just a few all
goes out of this entire set are needed
enables us to have an assay which has a
very high frequency of single molecular
detection despite the fact that the
target sequence the target RNAs are
typically going to be highly fragmented
uh potentially bound by protein
potentially degraded characteristics of
the sample which would typically make it
hard to detect RNA and fix tissue the
fact that we're using very short
oligonucleotides and and distributing
them across a region again is a feature
which enables us to detect transcripts
with with very high efficiency in in fix
tissue so this is our default we
typically use a pool of alga nucleotides
of this length it could be longer or
shorter depending on the on the target
sequence and just to kind of walk
through how this works again in terms of
sequences it binding amplification
through sequential hybridization steps
where we're hybridizing one I'll go to
the next to the next and then ultimately
coming in with either chroma genetic
enzymes or fluorophores as the label
much like you would do with IHC or
immunofluorescence but in this case
again rather than requiring thousands of
antibodies to bind to to thousands of
protein of epitopes we're localizing all
that signal to individual transcripts
and the other benefit of the assay is
that the signal amplification is
dependent on multiple things happening
simultaneously and as a result there is
essentially no background because it's
it's virtually impossible for a pairs of
all goes to hybridize right next to each
other in a random manner as a result
it's a very very clean assay which
allows us to quantify these signals as
digital measures of expression in tissue
this is just a very briefly to this this
slide here this is one of the first
publications in which a comparison
between RNA scope shown on the left-hand
side and the green signal you see
scattered around the nucleus is is her2
transcript and the panel of the graph on
the on the right-hand side is showing a
solution-based quantitative measure of
her to transcript from from HeLa cells
so both are HeLa cell samples one and
we're quantifying or measuring her2
expression by are an RNA scope and on
the right hand side we're showing a
quantification in solution and wonders
what you see the circled numbers show
we're getting very similar numbers
whether we count dots visually or
whether we use a solution based assay
and a standard curve of in vitro
transcribed message
and this this points the fact that when
we see dots the dots represent actual
individual transcripts which which we
can quantify using using various
softwares the software that that we
typically use is called halo from Utica
Labs other software is from de Finian's
Visio farm a cell profiler which is a
free software all those can perform the
same function and and these are
software's which are designed to
identify spherical round objects as dots
and then quantify those count those on a
personal basis and so we can we can
count individual dots we can count dots
based on different markers and different
colors to get measures of both
expression as well as percent itself
positive percent self-dual positive for
instance even even three we can look at
three markers simultaneously so we I
used this this example or this example
data shown on this slide to kind of
compare and contrast with a a sort of
the gold standard for molecular based
quantitative analysis nano string an
extremely sensitive assay which is it
does actually work on on formalin-fixed
tissue which also has a very wide
dynamic range the what's shown here is
the fact that we're looking at tnf-alpha
il-1 beta and ctla4 in non small cell
lung cancer tumors the numbers of the
top averaged dots per cell being less
than one per cell and whole tissue nano
stirring analysis giving a value of one
for each one of these markers meaning
expression on a personal basis is
extremely low almost undetectable
however what's obvious from a visual
analysis for any one of these markers is
you can see a very few cells expressing
it at quite high levels particularly in
the case of il-1 beta and that's the
value of a quantitative assay like RNA
scope which also gives you a visual
means of looking at expression on a cell
by cell basis so in that way it's been
used quite extensively to validate or
corroborate
Trench epidemic type approaches where
you can get information from an entire
tissue or cell population across the
entire transcriptome and then use RNA
scope to assess whether it's specific
cells in that population or expressing
or whether it's more uniform expression
throughout the entire tissue so the fact
that we can detect a very few dots
correspond to our acute transcripts
turns out to be very very powerful and
very relevant information about about
targets and biomarkers and that's
illustrated in the next two slides this
one is showing data from Bluebird bio
which is developing car T cell therapies
and this is in relation to RR 1 or
receptor tyrosine kinase which has been
considered a candidate for both ADC as
well as car t therapeutic development
and it's this data the data on this
slide which the primary piece of data is
in the in the center here and this is
showing a very low expression low level
expression of ro1 in Mouse of pulmonary
endothelial cells and this this
expression is entirely undetectable by
in situ hybridization excuse me ih C but
it is detectable obviously by by in situ
hybridization and although it's only
very few dots in a very few cells this
level of expression is sufficient for
engagement of car T cells that target R
r1 so the data shown on the on the right
hand side lower right is showing RNA
scope car T detection this is showing
detection of car T cells in the mouse
lung and the larger panel showing grands
IV expression is the result of RR one
targeted car T cells infiltrating into
the lung and attacking these cells and
resulting in you know grands I'm being
expression from from activated t cells
so this is a this point to the fact that
extremely sensitive detection in this
case points to the the toxicity risk on
target off tumor toxicity resulting from
low level expression in this case mouse
lung this this a level of
is was shown to occur in human long as
well which is why our r1 is no longer a
target for Carty development by I like
the Bluebird bio similarly this is data
from this is data from Merrimack
pharmaceuticals which also is targeting
in this case they're looking at the
expression of her regulan they have a
therapeutic program targeting Irby 3mm
121 is an anterior b3 neutralizing
antibody in clinical development and
they they determined that its expression
of her regulan which is the growth
factor ligand of her V 3 which is the
predictor of patient response and so
here again we're seeing very low level
expression represented by a few dots in
in this case non small cell lung cancer
tumor tissue from a patient it's this
level of expression although it's
completely undetectable by IHC it does
predict response and it was basis of
this these sort of results led to the
use of this assay as a means of
selecting patients for enrollment in in
later stage clinical trials so these two
pieces of data are just examples of
where very low level expression can both
identify potential adverse events or
toxicity if it's expression in normal
tissues or where very little of
expression in in tumor microenvironment
could point to a patient who would be
responsive but might otherwise be
identified as a false negative by a less
sensitive assay like IH c so just to
very quickly go through a couple of
examples of different kinds of assays
that can be performed with RNA scope
these are single marker assays either
using h RP or alkaline phosphatase on
average from tumor types we've recently
we and again we have assays which run on
both leica and Ventana platforms we've
recently developed some new and and and
significantly improved assays running on
the of antenna discovery ultra
instrumentation and this is the data
shown here is from that
this is just a tumor excuse me a tonsil
tissue showing some markers that are
quite difficult to detect by IHC namely
SIA CX c l9 cytokine and il-12 assign
the second il-12 cytokine and CX c l9
chemokine very little of expression can
be seen the red signal for il-12 is
quite low but but visible and again in
relation to RR 1 in mouse lung or
regulan in tumour that low-level
expression is likely to be meaningful
i'm likewise Vista and NT tudh
expression in populations of cells
within again within a human tonsil
sample some of the more advanced assays
we've recently developed and are have
recently commercialized involve both
combinations of dual in situ
hybridization combined with with IH c
and that's shown here looking at Fox p3
and tgf-beta by in situ hybridization
and combining that with cd4 IHC
detection also running on Ventana
discovery ultra instrumentation so these
are just hopefully more than just pretty
pictures good illustrations of of the
ease with which we can combine
essentially any probes any probes and
and some some antibodies where we are
continue to work on the validation of
different antibodies to be used in
conjunction with instances State
reauthorization probes and we're mostly
focusing on on developing HC essays for
cell markers that will work with with in
securitization as we feel that will be a
most of most value particularly in the
context of immune oncology but again the
fact that we can detect virtually any
transcript with are any scope roads we
have probes for nearly not all of it but
the vast majority of relevant targets
particularly immuno ecology and these
can be run on essentially any any tumor
type as well as normal tissues provide a
means of getting a very rapid view a
quick turnaround time a view of
expression in any sort of intact tissue
and so again to that point and and
speaking to the fact that it's used
quite extensively published frequently
on in papers describing transcriptomic
studies RNA scope is is very frequently
used to to validate results observed
either through transcript omics RNA
sequencing gene chip studies etc because
it takes so little time for us to
develop probes just a matter of two
weeks they're essentially ready to use
as soon as they're made and we data can
then be generated in a day so it becomes
a very efficient method both of
evaluating novel targets coming out of
transcriptomic sore or if there's a very
immediate need for for biomarker
development the the method to be applied
very quickly there as well I was
actually the situation with with insight
and their their idea one program they
had been working on an IH CSA for almost
three years and then realized that it
was not going to be sufficiently
sensitive to to meet their needs in in
clinical therapeutic development and
within just a matter of a couple of
months we were able to show them that
the RNA scope a state was about ten
times more sensitive than the IC I said
that they've been working on for so long
and since then we put this assay to very
extensive use to analyze a large cohort
of patients to measure idea one
expression across many many different
tumor types but there again a good
illustration of where we can develop
assays very very quickly demonstrates a
performance against other other
methodologies and and most often times
were able to demonstrate an assay which
actually has higher sensitivity and
oftentimes higher specificity than more
conventional IHC based methods so now
instead of segue into another area where
we're seeing a great deal of use of our
technology and we're really excited to
see the the contribution that this assay
is making in the context of Carty cell
and and TCR t cell therapeutic
development the illustrations here are
showing on the one on the left-hand side
the one of many lentiviral constructs
with a with a
chimeric antigen receptor insert in the
middle of it and on the right hand side
showing the resulting protein the point
here is that the the protein made by car
t-cells and TCR t-cells that protein is
almost entirely human or if not an
entirely human meaning it's it's nearly
impossible to differentiate a car
positive t-cell from a non car positive
t-cell in a in a human patient biopsy
in contrast the the transcript that's
making the car protein has viral
untranslated region sequences at the
5-prime and 3-prime end and these
provide unique sequence tags that are
only present in virally transduced
t-cells car t-cells TCR t-cells and this
has been put to great use and continues
to be adopted more and more widely as a
means of a tracking car t-cell activity
and car t cell tumor infiltration in in
patient biopsies so most of these trials
now appear to be involving taking or
collecting both pretreatment and post
treatment by off streets from patients
to assess tumor infiltration and
activity of those of those car T cells
or TCR T cells this is one example from
adapt immune presented last year at ASCO
and what's shown here is data that a CD
generated for them showing the the
infiltration of TCR T cells these TCR
t-cells are targeting the NYE so target
and the the TCR is shown in red and
again this is using a probe to a utr
sequence in in those t-cells and then
associated recruitment of of c3 positive
t-cells I'm using a green greenish blue
signal also an RNA scope readout so
that's one illustration another one from
this is from Juno actually two years ago
at a city meeting also showing pre and
post-treatment diffuse large b-cell
lymphoma patients and here they're
simply using a chroma genic div readout
to detect the presence of their car
t-cells in post treatment biopsies I use
this data this is from their poster also
showing detection of
one and PDL 1 by ite personally I felt
those images were not all that
impressive and somewhat difficult to
interpret and I use that to kind of
illustrate the both the knees as well as
the very high signal noise of comparable
assays using RNA scope in this case
showing I do one and PDL one of
detection with an assay which is much
cleaner and high as higher
signal-to-noise and can be easily
multiplexed so it I think it becomes a
much more valuable and an informative
experiment to be able to look at
multiple markers both in this case a car
transcript as well as markers that might
be related to checkpoint inhibition and
and and and t-cell inactivation like
like I do one and and PDL one a final
example preclinical data this is again
from some new bird bio keep credit to
Jim Rahman for collaborating with us on
generating these data also relating to
our r1 here showing again in the first
place showing the very low level
expression of our o1 in in mouse lung
and the result of treating these mice
with car t-cells at that target are l1
and that's shown here those in in that
same lung tissue what is shown and what
has observed our car t-cells
infiltrating into the lung becoming
activated as illustrated by current IB
expression and the resulting phenotype
being pulmonary toxicity and respiratory
issues be another consequence of the
t-cells infiltrating into the lung and
becoming activated there as they
apparently never actually reached the
tumor this is a xenograph tumor in those
same mice we see the same very low-level
expression of our l1 across the tumor
it's known to be positive for ro1 but
there's no red signal on the left hand
panel there's some green signal which
corresponds to two grand sign be but it
appears that the t-cells car T cells do
not actually
the tumor presumably because they became
they were sequestered or became
activated and exhausted in the in the
lung micro environment these are studies
these are studies done on on mice we do
just as many studies on unwraps other
therapy areas non-human primates for
partly for safety assessment to look at
target expression across normal tissues
we also do studies across normal human
tissues again in relation to target
safety assessment the areas where we do
a great deal of work in non-human
primate rat and mouse is in the area of
gene therapy and here again much like
the situation with with car t-cells and
TCR t-cells where we're using a viral
sequence as a means of identifying those
cells here we are detecting the AV virus
and so the the objective of these
studies in the interest of our clients
for whom we work is to look at the bio
distribution of of their aap gene
therapy vector we can do that with the
RNA scope assay so despite the fact that
it's called RNA scope AV DNA genomic
sequence is as accessible as is RNA it's
an episome 'el a DNA sequence not
tightly packed in chromatin like like
the like the genome of the species so we
can detect AV just as well as we can a
transcript so shown here it's a sort of
low magnification showing on the right
hand side a part of a nonhuman primate
eye where he was administered on the
right hand side showing no
administration no signal the probes are
using a combination of a probe to a CBA
sequence this is chicken chicken bait
albumin promoter sequence and GFP a
trans gene being used to look at
expression from that vector so if you
look at higher magnification what we see
is this bluish green signal in some
nuclei that again corresponds to
detection of the AV DNA which is nuclear
and then
the red signal which is predominantly
distributed across the the cytoplasm
outside of the nucleus and that's again
with a protein using GFP so this has
become also becoming a standard
methodology for as some Pfizer
investigators described it in a in a
review gene therapy review morphology
based biodistribution analysis is what
this provides in contrast to taking this
tissue grinding up and doing PCR to
measure the presence of a V another is
very recent paper just published in
Nature Medicine here again same same
story same application using RNA scope
to measure the the presence and in this
case the determining the localization of
their a vector to photoreceptor cells in
a in a non-human primate eye in this
case the what they're actually
delivering is a CRISPR cast nine
sequence of cows nine is being delivered
by by gene therapy with the intention of
gene editing to to correct ocular
disease so these assays everything I've
shown you in the previous slides are all
illustrations of the RNA scope
methodology they all work in essentially
the same way this very similar probe
designs whether they're running on
animal tissues or human tissues that's
essentially the same process and these
assays are all run fully automated on on
Ventana as well as like instrumentation
nacd we the majority of our business is
selling research products which which
are used by academic and and big pharma
companies we also offer pharma a say
services which serve primarily the
biotechnology community which does not
have which has not invested in auto
Stanners and other capital equipment
like that and for them we run thousands
and thousands of assays tens of
thousands of slides and again with a
feature of an assay which is which
requires very little development time we
can turn around results very very
quickly and what we this is gene
expression target expression or viral
distribution analysis
in in Brighton different issues
oftentimes multiplexed with with cell
markers whether it's normal cell markers
or tumor cell markers with readouts that
correspond to molecular detection which
can be which can be quantified on a
personal basis and so with that I will
say thank you again for your attention
and your time and I'd like to take any
any questions you have
thank you dr. bunker for that
informative presentation I would also
like to thank advanced cell Diagnostics
for making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that this webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
May 27th 2019 and as a final reminder
our speaker will follow up with any
questions you've submitted via email
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we'll see you next time goodbye